no it's
it it's not those transformers but but
they can do some pretty cool things let
me show you so
why did the banana cross the road
because it was sick of being mashed
yeah i'm not sure that i quite get that
one and that's because it was created by
a computer i literally asked it to tell
me a joke
and this is what it came up with
specifically i used a gpt-3
or a generative pre-trained transformer
model the three here means that this is
the third generation
gpt-3 is an auto-regressive language
model that produces text that looks like
it was written by a human
gpt3 can write poetry craft emails and
evidently come up with its own jokes
off you go
now
while our banana joke isn't exactly
funny it does fit the typical pattern of
a joke with a setup and a punch line and
sort of kind of makes sense i mean who
wouldn't cross the road to avoid getting
mashed but look gpt3 is just one example
of
a transformer
something that transforms from one
sequence into another and language
translation is just a great example
perhaps we want to take a sentence of
why did
the banana
cross the road
and we want to take that
english phrase and translate it into
french
well transformers consist of two parts
there is an encoder
and there is a decoder
the encoder works on the input
sequence
and the
decoder operates on the target
output sequence
now on the face of it translation seems
like little more than just like a basic
lookup task so
convert the y
here of our english sentence to the
french equivalent of porcua
but of course
language translation doesn't really work
that way things like word order in terms
of phrase often mix things up and the
way transformers work is through
sequence to sequence learning where the
transformer takes a sequence of tokens
in this case words in a sentence and
predicts the next word in the output
sequence
it does this through iterating through
encoder layers so the encoder generates
encodings that define which part of the
input sequence are relevant to each
other and then passes these encodings to
the next encoder layer the decoder takes
all of these encodings and uses their
derived context to generate the output
sequence
now transformers are a form of semi
supervised learning
by semi sequence semi-supervised we mean
that they are pre-trained in an
unsupervised manner with a large
unlabeled data set and then they're
fine-tuned through supervised training
to get them to perform better now in
previous videos i've talked about other
machine learning algorithms that handle
sequential input like natural language
for example there are recurrent neural
networks or rnns
what makes transformers a little bit
different is they do not necessarily
process data in order
transformers use something called an
attention mechanism
and this provides context around items
in the input sequence so rather than
starting our translation with the word
why because it's at the start of the
sentence the transformer attempts to
identify the context that bring meaning
in each word in the sequence and it's
this attention mechanism that gives
transformers a huge leg up over
algorithms like rnn that must run in
sequence
transformers run multiple sequences
in
parallel
and this vastly speeds up training times
so beyond translations what can
transformers be applied to well document
summaries they're another great example
you can like feed in a whole article as
the input sequence and then generate an
output sequence
that's going to really just be a couple
of sentences that summarize the main
points
transformers can create whole new
documents of their own for example like
write a whole blog post and beyond just
language transformers have done things
like learn to play chess and perform
image processing that even rivals the
capabilities of convolutional neural
networks
look transformers are a powerful deep
learning model and thanks to how the
attention mechanism can be paralyzed are
getting better all the time and who
knows pretty soon maybe they'll even be
able to pull off banana jokes that
are actually funny
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching